ladies our investment
note I wish to thank next
and it's brilliant Shepherds Rob reamin
Evelyn Raymond van Durham for giving me
the honor to speak before this wonderful
forum Nexus is one of the finest
intellectual intellectual marketplaces
in the world in the last two decades
I am excited and humbled to follow on
this stage in the footsteps of my great
predecessors let me begin on a personal
note again for many years I've been
getting up at 4 o'clock in the morning a
walk before dawn puts many things in
proportion
for example if on the previous evening
news a politician has used words such as
forever and ever for all eternity or
never in a million years at 4:00 in the
morning I can hear the stones in the
desert all the stars above the city park
quietly laughing at that politicians
sense of time I return home still before
sunrise make a cup of coffee sit at my
desk and start asking myself questions I
do not ask what the world is coming to
or what is the right way to go I ask
myself what if I were he what if I were
she what would I feel want fear and hope
what would I be so ashamed of that I'd
hope no one will ever know about me my
job is to put myself in other people's
shoes or even under their skins my
driving forces curiosity I was a curious
child almost every child is curious but
few people bring their full curiosity
into adulthood and old age
now we all know that curiosity is a
necessary condition even the first
condition for every intellectual or
scientific work but I wanted to end that
in my view curiosity is also a moral
virtue a curious person is a slightly
better person better parents better
partner neighbor calling then a person
who is not curious I even dare say that
the curious person is a better lover
than a person who is not curious but
it's too early in the day to discuss in
detail this aspect of curiosity let me
suggest that curiosity alongside humor
are too powerful antidotes to fanaticism
I have never seen a curious fanatic I
have never seen a fanatic with a sense
of humor fanatics have no sense of humor
and seldom are very curious because
humor undermines fanaticism curiosity
assaults fanaticism by introducing the
risk of adventure questioning and
sometimes even finding that your own
answers might be wrong
this leads me to the chief role of
literature in particular and art in
general their greatest merit is not
suggesting social reform or making
political critique you know the back
yards of philosophy and theology are
littered with skeletons of novelists and
poets who wanted to compete with
philosophers theologians ideologies or
even prophets a very few of them
succeeded but this is beside the point
bad literature can include very
important and even positive moral
messages and it would still be dead
literature the refining feature of good
literature and art in my view
is its ability to open a third eye in
our foreheads to make us see shabby old
things in a wholly new way Gamla maha a
notion Yashiro gosh and who led it even
an ancient vista has a moment of birth
as the great israeli poet not an
alderman put it great literature has
entered the shoes and skins of others
strangers sometimes obnoxious human
beings the donkey hurts the yeah goes
there are scholarly curves of this world
bad literature will not open a third eye
it will simply repeat only what we
already know and show us only what we
have already seen many times bad
literature in effect fixates the handful
of moral and psychological cliches that
gossip inflicts on us yes I'm sorry to
say
gossip is literature's poor cousin
although literature is ashamed of this
relative and will not greet it when they
meet in the street gossip is also a
child of curiosity but gossip loves
cliches
it loves reaffirming our prejudices and
it loves reassuring us that everyone is
the same good literature does just the
opposite of gossip it tells us something
we did not know about ourselves and
about others or something that it did
not want to know because while gossip
remains skin deep good literature can
sometimes accomplished the miracle of
delving under the skin and while gossip
intends to flatter us literature seeks
to trouble us thus a gossip will say oh
the man is getting old
a mediocre novelist will write all day
it is such a sad affair but Chekhov can
write about an old doctor bending over a
fainted girl taking her pulse rising up
and saying these four shuttering words I
have forgotten everything when I write I
do not chiefly address my readers
emotions although I speak with the
emotions - I do not chiefly address my
readers intellects although I speak to
the intellect - first and foremost I
address their curiosity I tell them like
a good tour guides would tell his group
to notice something fresh in a familiar
scenery - imagine what it would look
like if we stood not right where we are
now but if we stood on a high mountain
above us or down in the basement yard
where a woman is hanging her washing the
great israeli poet he who da amihai
wrote once i set on the steps of the
gate of david's tower
I placed my two heavy baskets on my side
a group of tourists was standing around
their guide and I became their target
market you see that men were the baskets
just right of his head there is an ah
there is an arch from the Roman period
just right of his head but he is moving
he's moving I said to myself redemption
will come right see who da me high
redemption will come only if their guide
tells them you see that are from the
Roman period it's not important but next
to it left and down a bit
there sits a men who bought fruit and
vegetables for his family so please do
not ask me to speak this morning as a
right there about
two state solution or the one state
solution I have been speaking my mind on
this topic for almost half a century but
I will say this my support for two
separate states one for the Israelis one
for the Palestinians does not stem from
the historians insight from the
politicians canning or from the
political scientists expertise I do not
have any of these I only have curiosity
and some imagination since my boyhood in
Jerusalem I've been asking myself what
it would feel like to be a Palestinian
refugee or not how would it be to live
in a Palestinians skin or harbor a
Palestinian Palestinians memories to
dream a Palestinian dreams while asking
this question I remain an Israeli Jew it
did not turn me into a Palestinian or
make II make me adopt every Palestinian
narrative and succumb to every
Palestinian demand nor has it led me to
turn the other cheek no but it had
inspired me to seek compromise